hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hardware review video and uh you may or
may not have forgotten about these but
these are the ifrogs uh custom fallout
headphones they're these over ear noise
isolating headphones from ifrogs and i'm
bringing them back for you here today in
a video so i can review them for you
guys
in case you're looking at a pair
and if you actually want to buy a pair
yourself and custom customize them to
look the way you want them to look uh so
here is uh the pair that i frogs was
kind enough to send out to me they are
like like i said the the uh the fallouts
are custom so you get uh you get to
customize the headband the side pieces
the speakers and the ear cushions and
the ear cushions are these these things
inside here
uh but i'll try to hold this up next to
a photo of what it looks like online and
this is what the actual headphones look
like and you get a pretty good idea that
they are uh pretty accurate online as
what they look like so if you want to go
ahead and customize those they can get
some pretty flashy headphones uh online
uh the way i've look you can get those
gold speakers the gray headbands some
bright red orange yellow whatever your
taste is but i went with a very simple
red and black like you can see
that my logo is red and black so what
else is uh unique about these headphones
uh i have to tell you guys uh first of
all there is a
relatively short cord i think it's about
four feet and it ends with a 3.5
millimeter headphone jack which is
standard it does not have a microphone
so you know uh your it will work with
your ipod your mp3 player whatever i
mean that's very standard stuff uh but
these headphones are very loud
and let me tell you guys i was using
these uh whenever i'm whenever i'm
editing i mean i use these as my editing
headphones guys that's how you know they
are quality these are my permanent
editing headphones whenever i need to
check audio quality make sure
everything's synced up whenever i need
to make sure uh the noise cancellation
was right i always use this pair of
headphones
and test it using uh using these
fallouts um because that is because they
are so loud over here that they
basically isolate everything else
outside all the outside noise and allows
you to comfortably comfortably listen to
uh whatever you're doing you can see
here
these are some pretty thick uh basic
pretty thick padding goes right over
your ear as you can see the inside there
is kind of hard to show you but that's
the inside right there i mean these are
great crisp loud headphones guys now the
only thing about buying these headphones
is of course portability will not be a
100 percent the the iproxx d33s that i
reviewed not too long ago
actually even came with a portability
case it was that portable
came in case about the size of my phone
right here actually smaller than that
because they are meant for portability
but the frog the eye frogs fallouts are
simply too big to be portable
which is really the only con about over
ear headphones you're sacrificing uh
portability i mean you can still pack
them in a bag or anything you'd like but
um that's that's the downside of it uh
but if you want to check out the specs
the link is in the description for
everything
uh so i'll put the ifrog's link in the
description the the core length is
actually 1.2 meters so you can do the
google conversion using that conversion
tutorial whatever you want to do to find
out your own unit but it's 1.2 meters
uh and it goes up to 120 decibels i mean
wait no sensitivity is up to 120
decibels guys and a 40 millimeter driver
unit so yeah i mean these are really
high quality crisp headphones i would
recommend these to anyone who was in the
market for headphones i i don't want to
make a headphone review boring guys but
honestly these are just a good solid
pair of headphones available for 34.99
at i ifrogs.com
and you can check out the specs and
everything there guys and i mean go
ahead and send me if you're following me
on twitter uh go ahead and send me a
twitpic of what you customize your uh
your falls to look like because i know
there are some pretty crazy design
possibilities with this multi-colored
artwork and everything that you can put
on these this outside here i just got
that simple red and white stripes you
can do really whatever you want so go
ahead and you know shoot me a picture of
what you customize yours to be anyway
this is what i customize mine to be
mkbhd editing headphones right here
great quality guys if you're in the
market for headphones you're going to
want to take a look at eye frogs and uh
that is basically it so uh thanks for
watching this review video there will be
more and uh thanks for watching guys
red peace peace